in the last video we tried to find the
area of the region i guess this combined
area between the blue and this orange
the area i guess the overlap between
these two circles and we came up with 9
pi minus 18 all of that over eight what
i want to do in this video you could
have also used a a typical graphing
calculator to come up with the same
result and it would have actually
evaluated the act the definite integral
so let's see how you do that and this
what i'm doing here you could do this
for a traditional what if you're dealing
with a
cartesian coordinates rectangular
coordinates or for polar coordinates
because it's really just about
evaluating a definite integral
so we wanted to evaluate 9 times the
definite integral from 0 to pi over 4
sine squared theta d theta so how do i
do that
well i can go to
second
calculus and i do the fn
int that's definite integral
so let's take use that function and the
first thing you want to say well what
are you taking the definite integral of
and we're taking the definite integral
of
the definite integral of
sine
actually i want the parenthesis sine
and i could use any variable here as
long as i'm consistent with what i'm
integrating with respect to so i i tend
to use just the x button because there
is an x button but we'll just assume
that in this case x is theta
so sine of x
squared
instead of sine of theta squared where
once again we're assuming x is equal to
theta
and then the next one you specify what's
the variable you're taking the integral
integral with respect to in this case
it's x if we put in a theta here then we
would want to put a theta there as well
and then you want the bounds of
integration and you should assume that
your calculator or
if you're doing this if you're in radian
mode or if you're dealing with radians
you should assume you're in radian mode
i just did before i
i evaluated this we're going between 0
and pi over 4
0
and
pi
over 4
pi over 4
and then we get
so we get this number and then we wanted
to multiply it times nine so times so my
previous answer times nine if i just
press times just as a previous answer
times
nine
is equal to this number 1.28429
so let's verify that that's the same
exact value we got when we and when we
actually evaluated the integral by hand
so if we take 9
9 pi
minus 18
divided by 8
divided
by
eight
what do we get we get
the exact same value so anyway hopefully
that's satisfying that we got the same
value either way and a little exposure
for how you might be able to evaluate
some integrals using a calculator which
can be useful when you can't actually
evaluate them analytically